hello everyone and welcome back to the
20/20 candidates tournament it's
basically the clash of leaders as young
a pony she's leading the tournament with
a full point ahead of everyone else and
in second place we have Maxie Marshall a
grub who is now facing Knepper with the
white piece so if you forgot since we
had a rest today yesterday these are the
standings after six rounds so like I
said young leading with four and a half
and the maxima shadowgraph in second
place with three and a half followed by
well everyone else so a pretty big deal
for both of them now let's check out
this very nice game and as we already
established on e4 which is a what Maxine
place for his first moving Airport
replies with East six again going for
the French saying that he prepared well
he did prepared for this tournament
definitely the four by Maxime we have d5
Knight to c3 and again Bishop to b4
going for the win over variation and E 5
we already had this game in the
candidates c5 a three and now no funny
business with Bishop f5 so Bishop
captures and c3b captures and the knight
to e7 and now a queen to g4 is by far
the most popular move here Knight to f3
somewhat less popular but also very
popular but here as alpha 0 pretty much
revolutionized to chess h4 by Maxine we
have Queen to c7 just continuing and now
even h5 preparing to completely dominate
the King side will h6 so never prevents
it with h6 and rook the b1 now because
whoever heard of developing your pieces
in the opening right b6 preparing to
either finca to the white bishop or to
trade off with babish of the age sex and
only now Queen to g4 by Napo and now
there are games where that reached this
exact same position were denied the FI
was played to guard g7 our King to f8 is
a no move but the move never plays has
never been played before and it is of
course such moves that we expect in the
candidates tournament rook the g8 and
here of course it's a new move as a move
10 we have a completely new game and the
magazine here started to I think about
the position a little bit and it's a
weird move because well either you
defend it with the king but now that the
roof is here how do you reply with
Bishop to be
five check do still move the King do you
block the bishop do you try something
else a lot of things to consider and
here we actually do have some nice
photos again of a nipple circling his
prey there you can see Maxime studying
the position that there's just a rose on
the board and also here's a very nice
photo of Neto
trying to intimidate Maxine with his
fancy route to GM while sipping on his
what could be coffee could be anything
really so let's just enjoy that for a
moment and after considering about
what's going on Bishop to b5 with check
waiting to see will Napa block maybe
Bishop to d7 maybe Knight to d7 or came
to f8 which is what nipple plays and
it's it's gonna be really interesting to
see what's what's happening here and how
will black get this get this rook into
the game it's really really difficult
but okay
a bishop back to d3 now the bishop is no
longer needed here as you've kicked the
King away and now Bishop to e6 hoping to
trade off the lights for bishops with D
captures on c5 and now B Bishop captures
on d3 we have C capture son d3 and now
Knight to d7 you're you don't have to
worry about recapturing right away
because even after Knight d7 white of
course cannot capture because of Queen
captures here with the check and after
Bishop blocks you're gonna pick off the
d3 pawn as well and it's gonna be better
for black so instead after Knight to d7
we have d4 and just strengthening the
center here and only now B captures and
c4 by Napo and now Queen back to d1
Queen back to d1 because if you just
continue development you might run into
something like character scalpers and
Queen c2 could be it could be somewhat
annoying
so before finishing development Queen
back to d1 now you can go night here
castle and so on maybe play a four maybe
Bishop to e3 to grab hold of this
diagonal but now Queen to a5 again
putting pressure on the c3 pawn here and
on the a3 pawn but now Bishop to d2 here
Maxime shows that he's not really afraid
of losing the a3 pawn because most of
the times you you just want to push it
all the way here and then
remove your brush up to a3 for example
even if you capture here Maxine would
most likely continue development and now
after you move away the Queen you have
to clear the way for 48-point to be to
start pushing it
castles let's say Queen to c8 and now
Bishop the c1 you're gonna shift the
bishop over to a three and it's it's a
not very likely that black will be able
to do something about this so and nipple
not interested in the a3 pawn look the
b8 instead and now comes Knight to e2
just continuing development and now
nipple is something that well is is
either good or bad but I don't know most
often when you see such a move it's not
good because well every every textbook
will teach you not the break tension in
the center that you wanna you wanna keep
rope on here to always have the option
of capturing and to to just well be
involved in the struggle for the central
squares but here you kind of block
everything and now it's pretty much
nipple who doesn't have to worry about
anything going on on the Queen side now
but okay
it's how he prepared this play and here
Maxime again started thinking a bit
probably between castling and maybe
shifting the rook over to h3 and maybe
bringing the recover to the attack the
rook would be helpful and h3 also
defending the third-ranked but he
decides for castles and the neighbor
just blitz his out rook to be sexing
that okay I probably had something like
this in my preparations at home and
Queen to c2 now connecting rooks and
also fighting for that f5 square at some
point f4 night the g3 and maybe f5 will
be an idea so the Queen and c2 will be
useful there rook the h8 now by neppo
also maybe not
not allowing this infiltration with with
Queen to h7 if it if it even does
anything and now comes a four just
clearing that a three square for the
bishop here and now with rook the h8 the
nipple probably cleared the g8 square
for the King maybe so you can bring the
knight over to f8 some maybe riemann
over it somewhere but now he instead
goes kink the yet and it's just a lot of
a lot of weird moves combined so first
you play rook to g8 that novelty then
you combine it would came to a faith
then you bring the
back to h8 and then you bring the King
back to eh so that's sort of a lie can
improve the bong cloud if you will but
okay now goes rook the b4 by maksim
preparing to double up rooks on the B
file and now Knight to c6 saying you go
back with that rook but maxime says with
your work on h8 that rook is basically
not a part of this game I'm just gonna
play f4 prepare my f5 and you are more
than welcome to capture my rook and grab
the exchange here however if you do so
Knight characteris C captures attacks
the Queen Queen a six and a f5 it's
pretty much well it's a terrible
position for black you're gonna bust
open the position and there not much can
be done here this rook is still out of
the game for example if Knight to f8
reinforcing e6 you're gonna go b5 grab
more space Queen to see it and now even
Bishop to b4 and it's just just a very
tough tough position to play for for
Black Knight is coming to f4 then you
can maybe capture here it's just gonna
be terrible so now instead after F for
an epic just goes back nice to East 7
and it is in fact the strongest more
recommended by the engine so basically
saying you and Knight to c6 wasn't all
that great so really a thematic game at
first that Ruby g8 wrote back tha King
f8 King back here now nice the c6 Knight
back to d7 that's some that's some
really impressive play by nipple but
okay rook F to be one now yeah there's
another thing you might try here just
reinforce f5 for example if Knight f3
wanting to now push that five black
would probably have to push that five
himself and after character scatters you
get to this position and it's hard to
say who who who comes up on top here
captures captures and now after f5 black
has this ePHI move as the you you cannot
capture due to the pin along this this
diagonal so it would be something to
consider but nvl finds something a bit
more easier to understand rook F 2 b1
just double up rooks here and now comes
f5 by black here nipple doesn't just
want to wait here although there was a
there was the interesting g6 which kind
of prevents f5 but it doesn't really
because after H captures F capture
you still push f5 and now after G
captors now you get again the F for
square for your night and now this is
week and you have to really know what
you're doing here but it is very
complicated Network not interested in
that he decides for f5 instead and now
Maxime doesn't capture on Poisson but
rather continues to work the b5 grabs
more space saying all characters are
favorable for me Quinta a6 and now
Bishop the c1 just shifting the bishop
over to this diagonal and here again
Napa plate King to f7 but there is again
this idea of g6 that might come in handy
maybe you will get some use for the semi
open G file for example if H captures
you're going to go rook the g8 and now
after Bishop to a three row characters
and g6 and it is a really difficult
position but at least you have your look
on the G file maybe you can put the H
point there could be some color up later
but but then again in Bishop c5 attacks
the rook characters character is Queen B
7 and then Bishop captures any 17
captures really a whole mess of it over
the position but it was it was there if
if nipa felt like it nipple didn't like
it he instead goes King to f7 and now
Bush of the a3 just continuing bishop
the a3 comes with the idea of fighting
for the f5 square once again and this is
how how he does it with Bishop to a3 and
now rook H back to b8 with the scheme to
f7 maneuver nepo now is finally
activating the Rooker for from a trade
and now it's Maxime to play so feel free
to pause the video what do you play here
keep in mind we fight for the f5 square
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations
unsporting that night is one of the
defenders of the f5 square and for
grabbing it not just Bishop capture
seraphs on e7 so congratulations
everyone
King captures on e7 and now G for this
is how we bust open done on f5 we have
rook address on b5 first by neppo a
capture Sun b5 attacking the Queen rook
after Sun b5 grabbing the pond and out G
captures on f5 with rook captures and we
want Queen captures and now he captures
on f5 and here what do you play Knight
the g3 by Maxime the the engine really
prefers King to f2 but it is something
that we will understand only later in
the game here he just goes for night to
g3 capturing right away might run into a
problem because of Queen e6 and you
don't really want to trade Queens
because black has the past a pawn he can
push so we'd have to go all the way back
and now Queen g4 check might might run
into some problems King F - you're gonna
capture on h5 and now even black has a
dis passport and this passport so it
could be could be could be good for
black so instead and Knights the g3 just
increases pressure here and now Queen
the Beast is by nipple just offering the
Queen trade but allowing this capture on
f5 a much more resilient idea was in
fact g6 and again going into this
captures captures at least now you're
pinning the night so the knight cannot
capture and you're not allowing Queen
captures because of Queen captures night
so here we would have to see King f2
that's why the engine preferred King to
have to at the beginning of this whole
line but then for example a5 and you
already get something going with black
however Neto went for this Queen to b6
idea and here he just allows Knight
captures on fi with check King to f8 and
now Queen to a1 preparing the Queen to
a3 check but all in all avoiding the
Queen trade Quinta East 6 now attacking
the knight and mount Knight the g3 and
we reach move 36 where Maxine has 28
minutes on the clock and nip or some 15
minutes on the clock
so four more moves needed to reach time
control and now you basically have to
decide between Queen to b6 where you
regard your a7 pawn but you just wait
for white
to play this game and there's nothing
much for you to do so any points that
goes Queen to g4 with some ideas of
maybe sacrificing the G point and then
you start pushing the H bond but came to
G tube first defending the knight and
now like we said g6 is a very
interesting idea
the problem is white doesn't capture and
allow black to push the pawn but rather
Queen to a5 with the idea of Queen here
and now the point is after capture is
Queen d8 check King to f7 okay the Queen
is guarding the night here but now f5 is
deadly
you no longer guard the night there's
just the threat of characters also EEE 6
is in the position and after you move
the knight you it's just game over each
sex with checking g7 we need 7 check
King g8 you're gonna check here King
moves and now e 7 wins the game nothing
to be done here you are getting
checkmated so nipple sees that g6
doesn't do anything so he tries Queen
captures on f4 first maybe he can start
delivering some checks here but just
Queen captures an a7 as the title
suggests cool as a cucumber and now
threatening to pick up the night Queen
to d2 chair not doing all that much
after you hide there are no more checks
so King to e7 defending and now Queen
back to a3 maxime got rid of the past
pawn and now he just brings the Queen
back to help out with the defense and
also Tori maneuver with the d6 Square
King Tubby 8 and the now comes Queen to
d6 and here we reach move 40 and nipa
still has 8 more minutes to make his
move and it's not not an easy position
to deal with here Napo decided to go for
g5 although there really isn't much more
you can do here you have to play
something if you move the Queen then you
allow if the Queen moves and releases
this pin then East is just wins you
cannot move the knight you could play
something like King King to c8
but then just Quincy 6 check followed by
characters here then you can start
picking off the pawns it's a very
difficult position so Knepper tries g5
he reaches time control with this move
but now maxime just plays h-cat force
and g5 with h5 threatening Age 4 but
here Maxine just plays g7 and it was in
this position that Janna pony she
resigned
the game and he loses his one-point
advantage in front of the field and the
maxime who like we said was trailing by
a full point now catches up to Nepal and
now we have a nipple in the maxime
sharing first place after the first half
of the tournament so now seven rounds
are over we're gonna check out some
other games from from round seven and
then I'm gonna discuss the standings a
bit but basically this is this is huge
huge victory for Maxine and basically
the the wild-card who who replaced that
image above in the candidates tournament
taking down the leader with without much
difficulty as it really was just a very
impressive game neppo really prepared it
but it's so hard to play this this King
to f8 vinegar variation of the French is
you can see he just went back and forth
rocky said Ruby g8 king of 88 and then
that that whole knight c6 back to d7
idea backed a seven idea really crazy
stuff but yeah it appears that the
hunter became the hunted and it doesn't
matter how much he circled his prey it
was it with a Maxima in this game who
was definitely the hunter so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Willie and Pinard
host overall dolly junior Simon Lawson a
Kevin Barnes and Stefan order for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos Aaron
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the
feeder candidates tournament until until
it finishes and and we know who will
challenge Magnus Carlsen for the throne
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day